[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA Qatar 2022 a
continuación nuestros titulares
La magia de Richardson inspira a Brasil
dos goles del delantero del tottenham
definen el resultado ante Serbia y la
canarinha hace gala de sus opciones nos
vamos a doha para revisar ese partido
armisticio en Qatar Uruguay y Corea del
Sur no se hacen daño y terminan sin
goles con los asiáticos proponiendo más
revisamos las las perspectivas de estos
equipos
Cristiano Ronaldo entra en la leyenda
abre el marcador en la victoria de
Portugal sobre ghana y hace historia al
anotar en cinco mundiales distintos
voces y balance más adelante
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio zas o periodista de Blu radio en
Colombia bienvenido Octavio Hola Omar un
gusto como siempre y También aprovecho
de darle la bienvenida a nuestro enviado
especial Juan pupiales quien nos trae
todos los detalles de primera mano de lo
que ocurre en Qatar saludos Juan
Omar Octavio un placer estar como
siempre con ustedes aquí en Diario del
mundial desde doha
Brasil prometía magia e hizo magia
además con efectividad ante una Serbia
que se reservó su Arma Mortal para
cuando era muy tarde richarlyson firmó
el 2-0 con un lujo de Gol la pasé de
vinicios en su segunda aparición en el
marcador Juan qué impresión está dejando
esta selección brasileña
pudimos ver una brasier a la que no le
da miedo la que no teme dominar el
partido salir Al ataque salieron con
cuatro delanteros algo con lo que ya se
especulaba era obtener afred en el
mediocentro o tener a Neymar como
enganche digamos con esos otros tres
delanteros al rafiña vinicius Junior y
richarlison cuatro delanteros una Brasil
que salió a atacar vimos aquí cerca de
90 mil espectadores en el estadio Luis
alvimos verdaderamente un estadio un
ambiente de fútbol una lente un ambiente
digno de un mundial el himno brasileño
se sintió con muchísima emoción no hemos
visto tanta hinchada en esta copa mundo
a los brasileños hicieron sentir Y
arropados por esa afición brasileña
Brasil salió al ataque con esos cuatro
delanteros como les digo pero se
encontraron con una Serbia que estaba
muy ordenada en defensa eran línea de
dirección de defensa venía en emaya
gudel el mediocentro de Sevilla que
bajaba también para terminar jugando
como un cuarto central una línea el
centro del campo terminaba a veces con
cinco jugadores cierto que hizo plantó
buena cara en el comienzo del partido
pero claro tenían solamente a mi trovich
en ataque Y eso limitaba muchísimo sus
ofensiva no sabemos Cuál era el plan al
completo de Serbia pero en esa primera
parte Brasil intentó llegar casi sin
éxito y finalmente de tanto insistir en
la segunda parte en ese minuto 60
llegaron esos dos goles de richarlison
Premium para richarlyson que es
debutante mundial en Brasil tiene vino a
esta copa mundo con nueve delanteros
pero bien da todo muy interesante
solamente Neymar y Gabriel Jesús tienen
experiencia en Copa mundo los demás
están debutando en una instancia como
esta hoy de momento uno de ellos al
Richardson cumplió y de buena manera
también lo hizo vinicios que en los
primeros albores del partido se lo dio
desbordando como él muy bien sabe Juan
como se explica que un jugador como
blowich que podía ser un referente en
Serbia haya sido usado cuando pues
prácticamente no había mucho que hacer
estamos a la espera que el seleccionador
nos dé más en detalles acerca del Estado
físico de blackovich porque toda la
prensa teníamos como baja casi segura
era amitrovich el delantero de la liga
premier pero fue finalmente blackwich
quien parecía que ya estaba en buen
estado de forma el que no arrancó salió
ya el terreno de juego cuando estaba 1-0
por debajo Serbia ya así era algo muy
difícil estaba muy cuesta arriba el
partido para él es la estrella de Serbia
de la Estrella de la Juventus y
finalmente no hizo parte de este plan
Serbia demostró que sabe defender
demostró que tiene una defensa rocosa
con defensas Como por ejemplo como por
ejemplo Black Pablo Quiche pero
finalmente no demostró Nada más quedó
endeuda ver algo más quedó en deuda a
ver una verdadera configuración en
ataque con microbich y con blackovich
Octavio la salida de Neymar se produce
por por problema físico por lesión pero
los otros cambios que vienen después son
estratégicos qué mensajes están mandando
tite porque es realmente un lujo de de
profundidad en lo que tiene que ver con
el juego de ataque no Exactamente La
verdad es que Brasil dispone como decía
Juan de una cantidad de jugadores en la
delantera que no tiene ningún otro
equipo eso realmente le da una ventaja
al equipo brasilero por encima del resto
tiene la capacidad o tiene la
posibilidad al menos tite de poder jugar
de tener esas variantes a la hora
incluso de darle descanso a algunos
otros jugadores o de pretender atacar
como lo hizo hoy desde el arranque del
partido Sabiendo que podía poner una
cantidad cualquiera delanteros porque
Brasil tenía que digamos tratar de
ganarle como fuese a ser y vida
utilizando su poderío ofensivo que es
quizás el mayor Baluarte que tiene este
equipo Entonces el él le está mostrando
al mundo ella Esa que tiene esa fórmula
que tiene para para jugar a diferencia
de otros de otros equipos que tienen que
jugar con con esquemas mucho más
conservadores la verdad es que Brasil
tiene para armar dos o tres delanteras
de de gran nivel Y eso lo dejó clarísimo
el día de hoy si Hablamos ahora del otro
sudamericano que estuvo en acción hoy
Uruguay que dejó una imagen mucho menos
Clara de sus posibilidades en el empate
sin goles frente a Corea del Sur vimos
un Uruguay muy vertical cayendo en el
juego físico de velocidad de los
surcoreanos Juan que podemos destacar de
ese partido
fue un partido en el que vimos para mí
una Corea del Sur que jugó un muy buen
fútbol lo venimos hablando aquí en este
programa las delegaciones asiáticas
están demostrando un crecimiento muy
importante el partido lo dominó Corea
del Sur y Uruguay fue hacia su partido
de esperar atrás y aprovecharlo poco que
tenía no fue un partido brillante de
Uruguay pero aún así tuvieron un disparo
al palo un cabezazo de godín y otro de
Federico Valverde uno de los mejores
jugadores de Europa por estos días gran
toque de balón el que tuvimos por parte
de Corea del Sur con Uruguay la sorpresa
estaba me lo comentó me dio la noticia
del propio loco Abreu que me lo crucé
llegando el estadio Facundo pellizque El
joven delantero del Manchester United a
quien Diego Alonso puso a debutar hoy
buscando desequilibrar pero no pudo
hacer mucho ante una defensa de Corea
del Sur que fue muy rocosa Pese que
físicamente no se muestran como unos
Defensores digamos de Gran talla pero
terminaron siendo una un un hueso duro
de raíz para los uruguayos con una
insistencia muy grande en el Cuerpo A
Cuerpo Luis Suárez yo lo vi incluso
hasta fuera de forma Darwin Núñez
terminó siendo de lo mejor que tuvieron
los charrúas ese mediocentro brillante
de vecino Betancourt y Valverde quedó
dejó en deuda en este partido de hoy
Uruguay que también efectivamente deja
muchas dudas en este encuentro ante una
Corea del Sur que como decimos que sale
faltó haber tenido un nueve más puro que
humminson para haber aprovechado esas
llegadas que tuvo en ese encuentro y
Uruguay ahora que tiene una prueba
difícil porque en el próximo partido se
va a medir contra Portugal que viene de
ganar Uruguay que terminó con empate a 0
en este encuentro y sabe que ahora es el
próximo partido contra Portugal necesita
sumar para llegar con vida de la tercera
fecha de esta fase de grupos Juan le
agradecemos muchísimo su aporte nos
encontramos en el nuevo mañana
un placer Pablo briche se llama el
defensa de Serbia que no me iba a quedar
sin decirlo bien
[Risas]
usando en las posibilidades las opciones
de cambio que tenía Uruguay Hoy hay
puesto hay lugar en este equipo para por
ejemplo un jugador como Jordan de
rascaeta que viene a quedar en el 11
ideal del brasileirado que que es uno
uno pensaría que puede ser una opción
válida Sí claro lo que pasa es que
cuando digamos es la forma en cómo juega
el equipo de Diego Alonso digamos la la
manera en como él va distribuyendo los
jugadores dentro dentro del campo de
juego y cuando él tiene a Suárez a Núñez
y a cavani evidentemente va a tratar de
por jerarquía primero jugársela con
estos tres y lo otro Es dependiendo del
río al que tenga enfrente buscará la
fórmula para para incluir el rascadita o
no hoy Lamentablemente para para Uruguay
se encontró digamos con con esa pared
que que significó Corea del Sur sobre
todo en la mitad de la cancha Corea le
faltó jerarquía porque porque
Lamentablemente Corea tiene solo un
jugador que puede marcar Esa diferencia
que son y en medio de los defensores
uruguayos pues no no era tan sencillo
Pero supongo que Alonso le buscará la
vuelta a la historia porque hoy no se
sintieron cómodos ni Suárez ni Nuñez ni
cavani Ninguno de los tres está en un en
un gran momento más allá de que viene
Suárez de ganar el título con nacional y
veremos ahora con un rival mucho más
complicado como se la puede jugar de
baloncesto y como si le faltarán hazañas
por completar hoy Cristiano Ronaldo
siguió haciendo historia en la sufrida
victoria de Portugal sobre ghana Natalia
Ruiz giraldo que también hace parte de
la presencia de Franz 24 en 2 a
compartir con nosotros detalles de ese
partido
Portugal contra gana era casi como un
David contra Goliat gana que es el país
que peor está en el ranking FIFA en este
mundial a los africanos Les costó
mantener el control de la pelota Aunque
lograron neutralizar a los laterales al
uso sobre todo en la primer tiempo pero
ya para el segundo en la segunda parte
de este partido pues esto llegó a una
especie de de las emociones A partir del
minuto 65 con un penalti a favor de
Portugal una decisión de pronto un poco
severa por parte del árbitro
estadounidense fue Cristiano Ronaldo El
capitán al uso quien marcó este gol sin
embargo fue luego el capitán de ghana
Andrea lograría el empate sin embargo yo
hago Félix cinco minutos más tarde
volvió a dar la ventaja de Portugal y
luego Rafael leado marcó el tercero esto
parecía que ya iba a quedarse así sin
embargo gana nunca bajó los abrazos y la
ilusión llegó ya sobre los últimos
minutos de este partido gracias a bucarí
sin embargo el tiempo no Fue suficiente
para que gana tratara de
finalmente con ese empate pero fue un
buen partido en medio de todo para los
africanos a pesar de que por ahora
ninguna de las Naciones africanas
africanas Ha logrado ganar aquí en
acatar pero si fue un partido con dos
récords Por una parte andreayo que se
convierte en el jugador africano que más
mundiales ha disputado y Cristiano
Ronaldo que se convirtió hoy con este
tanto Pues en el primer jugador en
marcar en 5 mundiales diferentes el
próximo partido de este grupo el grupo H
será el próximo lunes tendremos Corea
gana y Portugal Uruguay
Por cierto que Natalia pulsó la opinión
de aficionados que asistieron a ese
partido Y definitivamente los ganeses
hacen un buen balance a pesar del
resultado
Hicimos lo mejor y lo hicimos muy bien
pero hay una cosa acerca de mi equipo
acostumbramos a mostrar mucho respeto si
nosotros fuéramos hacia adelante
tendríamos mejores resultados Espero que
eso cambie en nuestros próximos partidos
contra Corea del Sur y Uruguay y de
hecho Uruguay va a lamentar lo que pasó
en 2010 mundo mucho cuidado con gana
definitivamente vamos a destrozar a este
grupo
Octavio le basta Portugal con lo que
mostró hoy porque definitivamente gana
como comentaba Natalia logró asustar en
los minutos finales sí digamos lo de
Portugal se descuidó un par de veces en
la zona defensiva y gana digamos con
velocidad con con físico lo lo incomodó
lo molestó incluso lo hizo sufrir más de
lo debido yo creo que Portugal tiene uno
de los mejores planteles de los
planteles más ricos que hay en la copa
del mundo sin embargo tienen que
terminar de aceitarse como como equipo
sufrieron mucho sobre todo en la parte
final del partido y si iñaki Williams
hubiese tenido mejor puntería hubiésemos
estado contando que el partido terminaba
tres a tres por un error grosero del
Arquero por falta de concentración en
Portugal las veces que se equivocó fue
por esta razón de todas maneras yo creo
que de la mitad hacia adelante Portugal
tiene muchísimo talento y a la hora que
se combinan yo hago Félix Bruno
Fernández Cristiano Ronaldo va a ser muy
difícil de pararlo si se encuentra en un
equipo que sea más abierto que los deje
jugar Portugal seguramente va a seguir
el camino de candidato que tienen esta
copa del mundo los resultados de hoy
dejan a Portugal precisamente al frente
del grupo H pero no hay distancias muy
marcadas en este momento luego de ese
empate sin goles del que hablábamos
entre Uruguay y Corea del Sur en el otro
partido de esta llave y cerramos
y cerramos con la victoria de Suiza
sobre Camerún con gol de abril en
jugador nacido en el país al que superó
de hecho su gol no incluyó festejo Y sí
una disculpa Octavio ya habíamos vivido
una situación similar con Suiza con
aquel gol de Shakira contra Serbia que
requiere un jugador nacido en kosovo
siendo estos dos países de la ex
yugoslavia pero esta es primera vez en
la historia que un jugador le anota a su
país de nacimiento significa esto que
que se difuminan cada vez más las las
fronteras en el fútbol totalmente el
fútbol el fútbol ya cambió ya más allá
de que haya selecciones puras de que
haya países como Brasil o como Argentina
Que prácticamente jamás van a tener
jugadores nacionalizados en el caso o en
el resto sobre todo en las fronteras
africanas y europeas va a seguir
sucediendo hoy el caso de embolo que me
imagino que tiene el corazón partido
porque termina marcándole un gol a
Camerún que lo puede eliminar siendo ese
su país de nacimiento y donde se crió y
y por ejemplo eumar vimos jugar a gana y
hay 14 jugadores de gana regados en
otras elecciones que si se juntaran todo
seguramente el aficionado danés
estuviera celebrando hoy una una
victoria Así que el mundial es así el de
hoy Precisamente es así y en casi todas
las elecciones hay jugadores que que
defienden a otros países como el propio
iñaki Williams por ejemplo en ghana que
es nacido en el país Vasco pero de
padres ganeses Él juega paraganes y su
hermano juega para España nos ha dado ya
un par de situaciones como esta porque
los hermanos boateng fue la misma
circunstancias exactamente Entonces eso
no eso va a ser de aquí en adelante Omar
seguramente va a ser así en la mayoría
de los países en los mundiales Octavio
Muchísimas gracias por su aporte
continuamos con todo este repaso del
Campeonato Mundial mañana hasta mañana
Bien también revisamos cómo queda
después de estos resultados el grupo G
con Brasil y Suiza en la cima pero los
suramericanos por delante por diferencia
de goles y se acaba de confirmar que la
ausencia de Neymar se debe a un esguince
de tobillo la salida de Neymar de un
esguince de tobillo todavía está
pendiente de nuevos análisis para
determinar si va a poder continuar o si
va a poder estar presente en el próximo
partido
vamos con una selección de noticias de
esta copa del mundo
siguen los agobios para Francia el
delantero 15 abandonó los entrenamientos
de hoy afectado por molestias musculares
hizo el calentamiento con el equipo pero
luego se retiró con molestias en un
aductor a la espera de verificar su
evolución de champs de momento cuenta
con 23 para enfrentar a Dinamarca
Marruecos también tiene dolores de
cabeza los defensas
y nos ha ido más rawi del Bayern Munich
que están en duda para jugar el domingo
con Bélgica los dos se lastimaron en el
empate sin goles ante Croacia y dependen
de exámenes médicos para saber si
estarán disponibles
[Música]
un exjugador de la selección
iraní-boriaga Furia ha sido arrestado
este jueves por insultar al equipo
nacional y hacer propaganda contra el
gobierno según versiones de prensa que a
Fury es un fuerte crítico del régimen
iraní y ha mostrado su apoyo a las
protestas antigobernamentales
mañana vuelve a la cancha el único
equipo americano que hasta hoy hasta la
victoria de Brasil había logrado ganar
hablamos de Ecuador que se mide a su
gran rival por el liderato del grupo a
Países Bajos mientras que en el otro
partido del día se enfrentan los dos
perdedores de la llave Qatar y senegal
en el vello chocan iraní gales a primera
hora y Estados Unidos e Inglaterra más
tarde
hasta aquí Diario del mundial los
invitamos a acompañarnos de nuevo mañana
y a seguir con la programación de France
[Música]